there's no doubt that the follow-up to
Avengers infinity war will have a hugely
dramatic effect on the Marvel landscape
from the beginnings of a new era to the
newcomers who will leave the franchise
into the future here are some of the
many different ways that endgame could
change the MCU forever the precise
details of actors contracts can be
tricky to pin down and it's only made
more difficult with MCU stars
thanks to Marvel's notoriously
tight-lipped style of doing business
however it's clear that endgame is the
end of the line for at least some if not
nearly all of the original six Avengers
Chris Hemsworth hinted in early 2018
that he was hanging up his hammers Thor
while Chris Evans teased an emotional
farewell in the fall of the same year in
addition both Vanity Fair and time have
reported that endgame finds all six
actors either at or near the ends of
their contracts I'm gonna miss these
little talks of Oz there's always the
possibility of renegotiation Robert
Downey jr. for example has already
extended his contract multiple times but
odds are that one way or another endgame
is going to be the swan song for the
sagas original band of Heroes it's a
heartbreaking truth of course as the MCU
has largely revolved around these
characters for over a decade but with so
many new adventures on the horizon
Marvel is sure to keep things exciting
even if it's hard to imagine a Marvel
Universe where characters like Hulk Bohr
and Black Widow aren't getting in on the
action while there are many familiar
faces that would be missed after their
departure from the MCU the hardest pill
to swallow coming out of endgame will
probably be the loss of Tony Stark
when Robert Downey jr. told the press
that he wanted his MCU career to end on
a high the message was pretty clear
there weren't going to be any more
contract extensions after endgame and
sure all good things do have to come to
an end but the absence of stark from the
larger storyline is almost impossible to
imagine the reformed billionaire playboy
has managed to influence nearly every
corner at the MCU
he's been around since day one was
pivotal in forming the Avengers and has
acted as a lynchpin for the entire
Infinity Saga storyline not only did he
have that prophetic vision in age of
Ultron but Thanos is evident respect for
the hero just underscores how important
Tony Stark has been in terms of gluing
the
see you together what happens when that
glue is removed it's a question that
will be answered soon enough Chris Evans
alarmed fans when he penned what
appeared to be an emotional farewell
after he finished his last reshoots for
endgame in October 2018 the uproar was
quelled a little when Vanity Fair
reported co-director Joe Russo's
comments that Evans was not done yet but
the Russo brothers have toyed with fans
expectations before and no matter what
either of them might say publicly all
signs continue to point to the
likelihood that Steve Rodgers will
finally hang up his shield an Avengers
end game whether it comes via retirement
or death the implications of Rogers
departure from the franchise are highly
significant like Tony Stark Steve Rogers
has had a prolonged impact on both the
Avengers and the MCU as a whole he
served as the group's moral compass
bringing a real sense of heart and soul
to the entire operation new characters
like Captain Marvel mean the Avengers
will have all the muscle they need
moving forward but it's hard to imagine
who could take Captain America's place
if he boughs out during endgame Marvel
has always had a hard time letting go of
their superheroes no matter how tough
the fight may be the sacrifices required
have hardly ever resulted in the literal
irrevocable death of a hero during
Captain America Civil War the worst
things to come out of the Avengers
devastating Feud were war machines
injuries and a few damaged relationships
if you seemingly permanent superhero
deaths in the MCU have either been
inflicted on one-off characters or on
those who still have at least a pretty
good chance of coming back an endgame
however there's a distinct possibility
that we'll finally witness the permanent
death of a leading hero and no plans
tomorrow night Anthony and Joe Russo
have remarked more than once that
they're determined to underscore the
action with real-world stakes in an
interview with Variety after infinity
Wars release the Russos warned fans that
although remarkable things can happen in
a fantasy world they have to come at an
incredibly high cost if endgame manages
to finally let go of one or more of the
lead Avengers say Captain America or
Iron Man for example it could completely
reshape the MCU canvas heading into
phase 4
and game is primed to continue the shift
in tone that fans felt at the end of
infinity war while there will always be
films like Thor Ragnarok and the
guardians of the galaxy franchise to
keep audiences laughing the future of
the MCU could be heading in a more
serious direction up until recently
Marvel's universe has tended to be
bright and colorful in its visual
aesthetic as well as its dialogue comic
relief was a constant presence and a
certain self-awareness of the suspension
of disbelief was always present
however as phase 3 wraps up the future
of the MCU is looking more serious case
in point the decimation infinity war
ended with half of all life in the
universe gone and while it was
technically the first half of a two-part
story the conclusion seems to only be
offering us another dose of heartbreak
as the team strives to fix the damage is
the end of phase 3 simply a blip on the
otherwise light-hearted Marvel Universe
not likely the higher stakes an end game
should have repercussions that will be
felt throughout the MCU for years to
come up to now the prime narrative of
the MCU so far has tended to focus on
earthbound heroes sure Thor came from
Asgard but even his storylines usually
moved between his own Kingdom and earth
even some of the more mystical heroes
such as Doctor Strange have gotten drawn
into the Avengers action from time to
time there's one group though that had
never met Hurst mightiest heroes prior
to infinity war the guardians of the
galaxy throughout infinity war the two
groups of heroes crossed paths on Titan
and in Wakanda
despite some rocky beginnings the two
teams eventually formed the United Front
against Thanos that was stronger than
the Avengers could have been alone the
trailers for endgame have already shown
that the remaining Guardians and
Avengers will continue to work together
that Alliance is a fun one to watch play
out an infinity war and the possibility
of seeing the two superhero groups
working together in the future is a
tantalizing prospect Marvel chief Kevin
Feige has gone on record to say that
Captain Marvel wasn't just an exciting
new face for the franchise
she was also quote as powerful a
character as we've ever put in a movie
by Gea's confirmation that Carol Danvers
is the mightiest hero in the MCU hardly
came as a surprise to anyone who saw
Captain Marvel
but the MCU is head honcho also casually
dropped a little more information on
Danvers regarding her future
as in the franchise after Marvel is
about to take the lead and be at the
forefront of the entire cinematic
universe while it's unclear just what
taking the lead will mean after end
games credits roll Danvers is a great
character to head up the MCS ongoing
story so will she actually lead the
Avengers as some fans have taken Feige
statement to mean the team already has a
pair of de facto leaders and Tony Stark
and Steve Rogers with downy and Evans's
contracts reportedly coming to a close
after this film there's at least a
possibility that their interpretations
could turn out to be correct
either way it's at least nice to know
that Marvel has another leader already
waiting in the wings in addition to
still under explored characters like
Black Panther and Doctor Strange
assuming they return to the MCU by the
third act of endgame there are plenty of
leaders in addition to Danvers ready to
take up the Avengers mission after cap
and Iron Man ride off into the sunset in
an interview with Empire magazine Kevin
Feige dubbed the first twenty two MCU
movies the infinity saga adding that
Marvel executives quotes wanted to bring
to a conclusion a series of movies in a
way that had never been done before it's
a fitting name as the stories of the
Infinity stones have been inter woven
throughout all three phases of the MCU
so far one town
five to go well the infinity saga has
been a heck of a ride all on its own one
side effect of II's comment is that it
is added yet another layer to the
categorization of MCU films now in
addition to phases we also have sagas
while anticipation for phase 4 has long
since reached a fever pitch especially
with Marvel about to take nearly a year
off before releasing any new films
the next thing bands need Feige to
reveal is what the next saga is going to
be titled unless of course he's planning
on waiting over 10 years and 22 more
movies before doing so the pair of
ant-man films that took place within the
nfinity saga didn't have too much of an
effect on the greater Avengers storyline
sure he showed up in supersize mode
during the airport encounter in Captain
America Civil War but that was about as
far as his role in the early MCU went
even after infinity war ant-man in the
wasp
stayed fairly narrow in its scope until
the credit scene showed us the faith of
the pimps and where Scott Lang happened
to be when Thanos snapped the second
film in particular also dove deep into
the concept of the quantum realm Hank
Pym hope Van Dyne and Scott Lang spent
the majority of a story trying to get to
the quantum realm and back in order to
try to save Janet Van Dyne who returned
with a ton of new information about the
mysterious otherworldly region while
ant-man in the quantum realm seems
certain to play a role in endgame Hank
Pym actor Michael Douglas took things a
step further during an interview on on
Air with Ryan Seacrest he explained I
mean the quantum realm that's because
that's the key that's the key quantum
realm plays an important part in all the
next chapters I think of the Marvel film
it seems the quantum realm will be front
and center in the MCU for years to come
in early 2018 Disney revealed that up to
that point Avengers age of Ultron was
the most expensive Marvel film ever made
with costs adding up to just shy of half
a billion dollars extravagant perhaps
but with most of these blockbusters
raking in a billion or more at the box
office alone the cost were more than
justified but the pricey productions
didn't stop there
the third and fourth Avengers films were
rumored to have a billion dollar budget
at their combined disposal with both
features being filmed back-to-back
that said Disney's reports also showed
that infinity war reigned in the
expenses to just under a third of a
billion leaving over six hundred million
dollars available to finish off the
story while the astronomical size and
scope of endgame certainly have the
potential to easily use up a budget that
large it begs the question how does that
lavish spending change the standard for
future Marvel movies is that going to be
par for the course in a few years if so
you can bet your bottom dollar the
already impressive quality of most MCU
films is about to be turned up a notch
or two check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]